bootleg cab podcast man we got a special
guest Rochester New York is here 4 48.
shout out to my guy pounds it's about
time man yes sir I've been waiting
listen you have like a insane
independent catalog yeah how many albums
uh 14. 14 albums out yeah what's the
latest what's coming give everybody a
quick rundown the last uh release was
Tony two that's from last year
um I took some time off got my [__]
together and now we back full swing Lord
mob 448 merger I gotta we kill
everything we see about to drop nice now
we got trapaholics mixtape dropping
directly after that
trapaholics I like it and then I got the
I got the album produced by Bohemia
Lynch homie from Japan that's super
duper serious drop and follow I just got
follow after follow-up so you're turning
up the rest of 2023 safe to say all the
way to 24. all right listen go follow my
guy uh at pounds 448 and he's about to
do what he does man come on yeah
yeah yes sir bootleg Kev yeah
huh
[Music]
yeah
my boy's cracking but we gonna get it
anyway
look
huh
[Music]
what you know about the burdens that
command go to work but ain't no thermos
in my hand I keep the curb service for
the grams you doing this service to the
fans when that paperwork surface it's a
stand you worthless as a man I don't got
a minute red bottom cobbler finish and
my pockets look like it's a novel in it
big Jewels one of these rappers but a
lot is running my shake blue body
snatcher you are not a menace I give a
[__] with another rapper doing did I
start to get the butter package moving
ahead of the cases keep the bread out
the Federal Savings for the travestyles
like gentrification wouldn't dare touch
it God that I don't care budget [__]
you ain't seen a lot of work till you
scared of it this ain't no microwave
wrap strike rifle band clap my sniper's
striking like a lady King patch
Godfather Top Shot of setting off the
shot spotted stones in the chain
straight from Botswana didn't know where
to stop Mama a whole lot of Fox on her I
just dropped the Box on your block shut
your [__] swapper I give a [__] if the
camera on the handing on mine know the
rappers I seen them yapping online you
trapping wrong Peter goat Capricorn
signs boxes at your door like this
Amazon Prime I ain't doing the corporate
job with the nothing for economy
fronting porta potty I'm thumping
talking spicy I might be just mob Wasabi
the mustard pork the family I'm doing
origami well hundreds
Minecraft
hey man did the LA we kicking my ass man
pounds 448 man you already know shout
out to the Mob Lord Lord that's how we
do things man that's how we do things
over here
keep it in that yeah shout out to
Bootleg Kevin he just he just hit me
with the uh funky gelato
freestyle guess what we're dropping them
every week sometimes more than once a
week Jesus we've been dropping a lot
lately uh shout out to LRG don't forget
go to
l-r-g.com use the promo code bootleg
save 30 off it check out you get this
look at this jacket look at that lining
it's LRG baby 30 off this bad boy go to
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg and save 30
off at checkout and check out another
freestyle next week